what up I'm Machine Gun Kelly and I'm
doing a wired autocomplete interview
[Music]
all right
what's machine-gun Kelly's real name
Colin Baker what was machine-gun Kelly's
first song probably terrible we won't
speak on it
what did Machine Gun Kelly say white
good children children's what did
machine I can't say nothing no snitching
what's machine gone Kelly's Instagram
well
fun fact my instagram name was
punch until a million followers and then
at some point I was like maybe certain
people might not want to associate
themselves with that so I just went back
to Machine Gun Kelly what our Machine
Gun Kelly fans called est everyone
stands together how machine hi Kelly got
his name I took it from the actual
machine gun jelly and paid a lot of
money for this how old mister how old
Machine Gun Kelly 29 for how tall is
Machine Gun Kelly in feet six foot four
and feet three thousand nine hundred and
sixty three centimeters in centimeters
three hundred billion and millimeters
and in human feet on 12
how was Machine Gun Kelly discovered
remember when Aladdin went into that
place and he found that lamp cuz Jafar
forced him to go inside his Machine Gun
Kelly single
ah man it's mushy yes I'm dating its
Machine Gun Kelly an actor no a dude
sucks is Machine Gun Kelly from
Cleveland 100% is Machine Gun Kelly and
Motley Crue
100% I took drum lessons for four months
for this movie you want to see my drum
instructor come here wrote goodbye wrote
who Machine Gun Kelly y'all are funny
man who is Machine Gun Kelly 's daughter
the Queen of Planet Earth her name's
Casey she just turned 10
happy birthday who signed Machine Gun
Kelly I signed myself to myself and then
I signed with puff and Interscope who is
the break-up by Machine Gun Kelly about
I'm actually friends with that person so
I can't say that because we're friends
so I have to see that person all the
time and it'd be weird who is the
drummer for Machine Gun Kelly get back
out here rut get back up yeah does
Machine Gun Kelly
you have a wife you guys are really
really mean you're all very very cruel
does machine guy write his own songs
yeah for sure all my and other people
songs too does Machine Gun Kelly play in
instruments I play drums I play guitar I
play my voice first thing I ever played
was a we all take that step of playing
that stupid recorder in school did
anyone ever get good at those like no
one ever mastered the recorder right we
all just gave up on that like two weeks
in I had that recorder and then like
violin I remember there's a picture of
me playing for yo-yo ma if anyone's not
in the violin community yo-yo Ma's a big
deal yeah then I smoked weed and got in
trouble and followed up so does Machine
Gun Kelly have an opening act yeah bad
jokes you want to hear one knock-knock
cargo cargo beep beep it's a really
should be opening act you should see
that liner does Machine Gun Kelly have a
criminal record
yep we all do that one so also very
cruel well this is Machine Gun Kelly and
I've admitted to many things so thank
you wired bye